[Musique]
si vous deviez définir l'optimisme
vous diriez quoi et bien la plupart des
gens parlent d'une humeur d'un trait de
personnalité assez tranché avec d'un
côté ceux qui voit tout en rose
presque trop naïvement et puis par
contraste de l'autre ceux qui voit tout
en noir les rabat joie et puis en
général on se situe plutôt entre les
deux avec la capacité de bouger d'une
option à une autre en fonction des
circonstances
mon approche est assez différente
je parle d'un optimisme conscient
réaliste et actif une forme humaine de
l'énergie nous avons une définition en
psychologie comportementale qui définit
l'optimisme comme une attitude mentale
qui favorise l'expérience d'émotions
positives pour les choses à venir
autrement dit c'est pas un truc qu'on a
ou qu'on a pas mais c'est une panoplie
de compétences qui s'apprend et se
propage de nombreuses recherches se
concentrent sur l'impact de cette
énergie positive dans la transformation
des organisations
plus précisément il s'agit d'évaluer et
d'adapter la quantité et la qualité
d'optimisme et changer de l'individu au
système et du système à l'individu comme
une contamination positive volontaire ce
moment là a marqué mon enfance
parce que quand cette image est apparu
sur le petit écran toute ma famille a
sauté de joie et ils avaient au moins le
même enthousiasme que les gens de la
nasa
alors pour moi ça a été une très grande
surprise parce que je savais pas du tout
jusque là qu'ils avaient participé au
lancement du projet et puis quand mon
petit cousin a couru autour de la table
en disant moi on va aller se promener
dans les étoiles alors allah alors on
n'y est pas tout à fait mais on sait que
c'est une possibilité mais ce qui est
intéressant dans cet exemple c'est ce
qu'on peut réaliser grâce à l'optimisme
collectif ce grand pas pour l'humanité
comme l'a dit cet astronaute ceux promis
ce n'est pas un leader qui l'a décidé
c'est ma famille enfin c'est nos
familles
c'est tous les enfants qui depuis si
longtemps ont levé les yeux au ciel en
espérant aller se promener dans les
étoiles et l'optimisme
nous avons tous un capital de départ
cette course là que vous me croyez ou
pas vous l'avez gagnée
vous et pas quelqu'un d'autre vous est
le fruit de l'optimisme du principe de
la vie alors vous pouvez vous le dire
vous pouvez vous le dire au quotidien je
suis unique et magnifique
si si tous absolument tous c'est tout
simplement vrai ce qui est vrai aussi
c'est que ça demande un peu
d'entraînement de le croire et puis de
se le dire mais vous ne partait pas de
rien votre capital de départ
vous l'avez fait fructifier vous l'avez
fait fructifier chaque fois que vous
avez pris une décision importante
audacieuses comme par exemple vivre à
deux avoir des enfants lancé un projet
bien
rappelez-vous les moindres détails de ce
moment de cette énergie au top
ressentez les à nouveau vos pensées vos
émotions vos sensations votre corps
puisque vous avez mobilisé ses
ressources alors vous pouvez à nouveau
le faire l'optimisme c'est comme un
muscle qu'on peut développer et
entraîner alors bien sûr il n'y a pas
une seule méthode valable pour tout le
monde
chacun doit trouver la sienne et chacun
peut adapter son niveau d'énergie à ses
besoins si vous visualisez un curseur de
1 à 10 et puis que vous placez votre
niveau d'optimisme
et puis ces fluctuations
vous pouvez alors y accorder bas la même
attention que vous le feriez avec la
charge de votre téléphone suffit d'y
penser et on y pense pour notre
téléphone alors pourquoi pas y penser
pour notre optimisme
et puis aussi trouver la bonne connexion
de bons réseaux on va pas tous avoir le
même bien sûr et une fois que vous avez
cela vous pouvez l'activer en fonction
de tous vos besoins
et maintenant il y à une question de
timing de tempo cultivez votre optimisme
en premier je dis bien en premier avant
de prévoir ou bien parfois de subir un
changement c'est justement ce qui vous
permet de grandir d'avancer aussi
logique que de faire le plein avant de
prendre la route
et puis aussi il ya autre chose il y a
savouré sa réussite au tout début d'un
projet visualiser mais alors comme au
cinéma
tout ce que vous voulez accomplir
réjouissez-vous par anticipation
ça c'est une super habitude mais pas que
c'est aussi une stimulation très
efficace quand la joie précède cet
accomplissement
c'est un véritable antidote au stress
on en a besoin non et puis aussi un
palliatif à la sinistrose ambiante
l'optimisme bas ça s'apprend comme on le
ferait d'une langue d'un instrument de
musique d'un sport on pratique on
pratique on pratique mais avec
l'optimisme on a un bonus supplémentaire
l'impact est décuplée quand on est à
plusieurs
si j'en reçois j'en ai plus et ce qui
est important c'est que si j'en donne
jean n'est plus aussi mon niveau monte
imaginez cela dans les écoles dans les
familles au travail une personne
souriante épanouie qui cherchent des
solutions plutôt que de ruminer des
problèmes ça stimule tout le monde
toute l'équipe de plus en plus
d'organisations se trouve sensibiliser à
une transformation culturelle qui donne
de la place à cette énergie positive
quand ensemble on croit que l'impossible
est possible alors celle devient ce
qu'on a fait pour aller à la conquête de
l'espace et puis toutes nos grandes
innovations
c'est la preuve qu'on peut changer de
paradigme chaque pensée chaque petit
geste est agissant pour contribuer à un
monde meilleur pour soi et et plus
encore alors dans les organisations
quand la priorité c'est de devenir plus
humain de donner plus l'opportunité de
vivre l'expérience de l'optimisme les
lignes bougent
on passe de la recherche du profit à la
quête de sens à la vision partagée et ça
ça donne plus de clarté plus
d'inspiration au quotidien on passe des
structures hiérarchiques
à des structures de réseaux dans
lesquels chacun peut exprimer ses
talents avec beaucoup plus d'autonomie
on passe de la pratique du contrôle à la
responsabilisation individuelle et d'
équipe
et puis on passe des pratiques de
planning de procédures très strictes à
un développement continu une
expérimentation un apprentissage par les
succès comme par les erreurs et puis
enfin on arrête avec la culture des
silos du secret de la rétention de
l'information et on passe à des
structures plus plate plus fluide à la
transparence au flot des informations
autant opérationnel que stratégique
les résultats sont très encourageants
et puis il ya encore plein de
découvertes à venir la semaine dernière
j'étais dans une école du kerala c'est
une province du sud-ouest de l'inde
magnifique il y a quelques mois ils ont
subi de très graves inondations
les dégâts matériels ont été
considérables et il ya eu des centaines
de morts
la semaine dernière c'était la fête
nationale les villes étaient décorés
partout des ballons des fleurs une
explosion de couleurs et surtout surtout
les villages des sourire resplendissant
m'aider si beau sourire
cette capacité de résilience de courage
de joie ça m'a tellement impressionné
c'est exactement cet optimisme de
culture que je rêve de voir se répandre
partout et vous tous aussi unique aussi
magnifique que vous êtes et vous avec le
plein d'optimisme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]